>>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
WILDEST PART OF THE CONSPIRACY
THEORY COMMENT SECTION GETS
ELECTED TO CONGRESS?
YOU GET PAUL GOSAR.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID TWO WEEKS
BEFORE REPUBLICANS IN HIS STATE
ANNOUNCED THEY HAD FOUND NOTHING
BUT ADDITIONAL VOTES FOR JOE
BIDEN IN THEIR BOGUS ELECTION
RESULTS IN ARIZONA'S MOST
POPULUS COUNT.
>> WE CAN DO THAT AND FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THIS AUDIT, FOLKS, IF
IT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD, AND I
HAD PEOPLE COME TO ME EARLY
HOURS THE DAY AFTER FROM THE
SECURITY EXCHANGE FRAUD
DEPARTMENT TO THE CIA FRAUD
DEPARTMENT, BETWEEN 450 AND
700,000 BALLOTS WERE ALTERED IN
THE STATE OF ARIZONA.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE CIA FRAUD
DEPARTMENT, NOT A THING.
DOESN'T EXIST.
HE JUST MADE THAT UP.
IF IT DID EXIST, SAFE TO SAY IT
WOULDN'T COME TO PAUL GOSAR.
IT IS AN INTELLIGENCE AGENCY NOT
A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
BUT HE DOESN'T LET THAT GET IN
THE WAY OF HIS CUCKOO FOR COCOA
PUFFS THEORIZING.
>> WE HAVE TO CHARGE PEOPLE.
SO WHAT I'M TELLING YOU, THE
GOVERNOR KNEW EXACTLY WHAT I
JUST TOLD YOU, AND HE STILL
CERTIFIED IT.
ON JANUARY 6th PEOPLE DID NOT
LISTEN TO WHAT I SAID.
WHAT I ASKED FOR IS A 10-DAY
WINDOW TO ACTUALLY DO A FORENSIC
HAND COUNT OF THE BALLOTS.
AT LEAST THOSE SIX STATES BUT
ANY STATES THAT WANTED IT.
10 PLUS 6 IS 16.
>> THE SHAM AUDIT PRODUCED
NOTHING EXCEPT MORE VOTES FOR
JOE BIDEN AND FEWER FOR DONALD
TRUMP.
WHAT WAS HAILED AS THE ULTIMATE
PROOF OF TRUMP'S'S VICTORY
SHOULD TURN OUT TO BE A BIG WIN
FOR BIDEN'S WIN.
ABOUT YOU WAIT FOR IT.
MORE BIG LIES.
>> AND YEAH.
AND THE THING ABOUT IT IS GIVEN
THE TOOLS, MY SUGGESTION WAS TO
HAVE HEARINGS ON THAT.
AND LOOK OVER A SET OF NEW
ELECTION FOR BIDEN AND TRUMP
>> HE IS PROPOSING A NEW
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION FOR JOE
BIDEN AND DONALD TRUMP THIS
YEAR.
THE CHANCES OF THAT ARE SLIMMER
THAN A GOSAR SIBLINGS FAMILY
REUNION.
YOU MAY RECALL HE HAS SIX
SIBLINGS WHO FILMED POLITICAL
ADS FOR A CHALLENGER AFTER GOSAR
CLAIMED THE WHITE SUPREMACIST IN
SHATTERINGSVILLE WAS FALSE FLAG
OPERATION.
ONE OF HIS BROTHERS CALLED HIM A
TRAEULTOR TO THIS COUNTRY AND,
QUOTE, A TRAITOR TO THEIR
FAMILY.
BACK TO THE SHAM ARIZONA AUDIT
RELEASE.
ON THE EVE OF THE AUDIT'S
FINDINGS, GOSAR TWEETED AN
ANTICIPATORY TOMORROW MESSAGE
SAYING LEFTISTS HAVE WORKED
THEMSELVES INTO A FROTH TO STOP
THE AUDIT.
THE CONSPIRACY THEORIES ARE AN
OLD HAT.
HE CALLED IT A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
NEWS FLASH.
IT ISN'T.
IT DOESN'T.
AND IF IT WERE A SLIPPERY SLOPE,
WELL, IT'S ONE THAT THE
CONGRESSMAN LIKES TO SKI DOWN
HIMSELF.
THE ARIZONA MIRROR REPORTING
THAT PAUL GOSAR VOTED BY MAIL
EIGHT TIMES THE LAST DECADE.
NOVEMBER 4th HE TWEETED, DON'T
LET THEM STEAL OUR VOTES.
THEN HE MADE A GIANT SLALOM OF
THE BIG LIE, CARRYING IT ALL THE
WAY TO JANUARY 6th.
>> I RISE UP FOR MYSELF AND 60
OF MY COLLEAGUES TO OBJECT TO
THE COUNTING OF THE ELECTORAL
BALLOTS FROM ARIZONA.
>> IS THE OBJECTION IN WRITING
AND SIGNED BY A SENATOR?
>> YES, IT IS.
>> IT IS.
>> THE INSURRECTION DIDN'T PUT A
DAMPER IN HIS ENTHUSIASM FOR THE
BIG LIE.
IT EMBOLDENED THE CONGRESSMAN.
HE CLAIMED THE ATTACK HAD
HALLMARKS OF ANTIFA PROVOCATION.
THE FBI DIRECTOR TESTIFIED
THAT'S BOGUS.
THEN IN A FUND-RAISING EMAIL
OBTAINED BY THE "WASHINGTON
POST", GOSAR FLOATED THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THE FBI
HELPED PLAN AND EXECUTE THE
ATTACK.
BASELESS, OF COURSE.
THEN HE ATTACKED CAPITOL POLICE
SAYING THEY EXECUTED ASHLI
BABBITT, WHEN SHE WAS CLIMBING
THROUGH THE WINDOW OF THE DOOR
WHEN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WERE
TAKING REFUGE, FEARING FOR THEIR
LIVES.
.
>> THE POLICE OFFICER WHO DID
THAT APPEARED TO BE HIDING AND
LYING IN WAIT AND GAVE NO
WARNING BEFORE KILLING HER.
.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT RULED
THAT THE OFFICER WILL NOT BE
CHARGED.
HE DID WARN THE RIOTERS
REPEATEDLY, HE SAYS.
GOSAR HAS GONE ON TO DEFEND MANY
OF THE INSURRECTIONISTS WHO HAVE
BEEN CHARGED.
>> MY CONSTITUENTS DEMAND
ANSWERS.
THE TRUTH IS BEING SENSORED AND
COVERED UP.
THE DOJ IS HARASSING PEACEFUL
PATRIOTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> PEACEFUL.
PEACEFUL, HE SAYS.
PATRIOTS, HE SAYS.
JUST ANOTHER FAKE CLAIM FROM
ARIZONA'S ENTERS THEORIST
CONGRESSMAN WHO SEEMS TO
REPRESENT THE TWILIGHT ZONE MORE
THAN ARIZONA'S FOURTH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU, THE MOST
CONCERNING THING ABOUT THIS IS
YOU CAN'T DISMISS PAUL GOSAR AS
FRINGE ANYMORE.
.
>> CORRECT.
>> THAT'S THE SCARY THING HERE,
IT'S NOT THE TWILIGHT ZONE.
IT'S REPUBLICAN ZONE.
IT IS RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
WHERE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
TODAY, WHEN 78% OF REPUBLICANS
TELL US THEY DON'T THINK JOE
BIDEN WON THE ELECTION.
.
>> YEAH.
TOTALLY AGREE.
THE OTHER THING, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES YOU LISTEN TO SOME OF
THE BIG LIARS.
AND YOU CAN TELL THERE ARE SOME
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE KIND OF
PLAYING ALONG WITH IT.
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TO SAY IT
BECAUSE IT HAS BECOME A LITMUS
TEST FOR REPUBLICANS.
OR THERE'S SOME REPUBLICANS WHO
THINK MAYBE THEY REALLY BELIEVE
IT.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU IT'S HARD
WITH PAUL GOSAR TO KNOW IF HE
DOESN'T BELIEVE IT, HE'S VERY
CONVINCING HE DOES.
>> I WOULD SUBMIT IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHETHER THEY BELIEVE IT
OR NOT.
>> CORRE